jurassic world dominion features the
reunions of some beloved characters
references to spielberg and star wars
and maybe the most resilient barbasol
can in the history of the world these
are all of the small details you missed
in jurassic world dominion near the
beginning of jurassic park dr alan grant
is lecturing about velociraptors at a
dig site as dr ellie sattler listens in
it's implied they're a couple since they
talk about the fact that she wants kids
and he doesn't in allen's humble
slightly cluttered camper turned
workstation is dr hammond waiting with a
bottle of champagne that's when he
recruits them to come to jurassic park
to provide testimonials so that he can
convince lawyers it's safe to open the
scene effectively serves as the inciting
incident for the whole jurassic series
what kind of park is this
it's right up your alley
in jurassic world dominion ellie finds
alan at a dig site again where tourists
are funding his research she's waiting
for him in his tent which looks much
like his old camper this time she
recruits him to help end the ecological
disaster that jurassic park and the
subsequent misuse of its scientific
breakthroughs have caused prehistoric
locusts will wipe out the world's grain
supply within a matter of weeks and
after visiting a decimated farm that
sits next to a biosin farm she
hypothesizes that the biotech company is
behind the giant buds dr grant quickly
hides a photo of the two of them that
he's kept all these years their
relationship ended after the first film
but it's rekindled here so this scene
and its implications operate as a mirror
image together they fight to avert
disaster and maybe even find happiness
together
steven spielberg is a child of divorce
it's a subject that often shows up in
his movies and it's a running theme
throughout the jurassic park franchise
even after spielberg left the director's
chair following the lost world in the
original jurassic park dr ian malcolm
says that he's always on the lookout for
his next ex-wife as he explains that he
has three kids from multiple marriages
one of them gets more attention than the
others when she tags along in the lost
world
hey i'm not the one who
dumped you here and split for paris so
don't take it out on me
more important to the plot is the
pending divorce of dr john hammond's
daughter that's why he invites the
children lex and tim to the island in
the first place to distract them as the
bitter court battle between the parents
plays out in jurassic park 3 paul and
amanda kirby trick dr grant into taking
them to isla sorna by pretending to be a
wealthy couple willing to invest in his
work really they're the divorced parents
of eric the boy who went missing while
parasailing with his mom's boyfriend
jurassic world recycles the original's
plotline by putting claire in charge of
her sister's sons zach and gray while
their parents hammer out the details of
their separation which weighs heavily on
the kids despite everyone's best efforts
to shield them from it jurassic world
dominion makes mention of at least three
more divorces ian now has five ex-wives
and ellie is no longer with her husband
with whom she has two adult children
ian's lost loves just add to his
character development as an
appropriately chaotic chaos theorist
while ellie's divorce allows her and
alan to reconnect
although fans have always admired dr
ellie sattler for much more than her
personal style it's hard to deny that
her classic ensemble consisting of a
button-down shirt with a t-shirt
underneath khaki shorts and a great pair
of shades is an iconic look working in
the elements ellie doesn't over
accessorize so whatever pieces she
chooses have to have some significance
throughout jurassic world dominion ellie
can be seen wearing a ring that appears
to be an oval piece of amber with
something trapped inside this is surely
not by accident it's a clear allusion to
dr hammond's walking stick with a
mosquito encased in amber from jurassic
park one of the more memorable moments
in the original film comes when dr
sadler comforts a sick triceratops in
jurassic world dominion she sees some
recently rescued dinosaurs in a holding
area at biosin one of them is a very
young recovering triceratops that biosin
took possession of from an illegal
breeding operation ellie crouches down
and examines the little guy's eyesight
as she says smiling you never get used
to it this scene calls back to one of
her first face-to-face meetings with a
real dinosaur it also shows that while
ellie doesn't approve of the way injen
or biosen conduct their science she is
still in awe of the actual dinosaurs
they produce
colin travarro was steven spielberg's
hand-picked successor to take over the
jurassic park franchise travaro directed
the first jurassic world movie and he
also has a screenwriting credit on all
three films in the second trilogy
jurassic world was such an enormous hit
in fact that star wars came calling next
trevaro was slated to helm the rise of
skywalker but was fired when he and his
producers had creative differences
during the development process trevorrow
apparently still has a fondness for the
star wars galaxy during one of the most
adrenaline-fueled scenes in jurassic
world dominion owen and claire go
looking for maisie in an underground
market in malta where they hope to meet
up with owen's old pal barry who's deep
undercover with the illegal traders
trevorrow told empire magazine that he
was inspired by star wars location moss
eisley and that he wanted his criminal
underworld to feel like the notorious
hive of scum and villainy in a new hope
so if you get cantina vibes from the
color palette the mysterious strangers
and the other worldly creatures in cages
and fighting pits it's intentional if
it's been a while since you've seen the
first jurassic park or if you've never
read the michael crichton book upon
which it's based you might think that
biosen is just the latest stand-in for
any nefarious multi-national biotech
company at the beginning of the film we
learned that biosen won a government
contract to provide dinosaurs with a
sanctuary at their old amber mines where
they'll study their dna for the purposes
of making advancements in human health
care but really dr louis dodgson is
trying to control the world's food
supply with bios and branded crops that
can't be eaten by his secretly biosyn
branded giant locusts biosen has
actually been a major player in the
jurassic park story since the very
beginning in the novel and to a lesser
extent in the first film biosen is
engine's rival and it's desperately
trying to keep up with the competition's
progress often through unsavory
practices like stealing intellectual
property the book notes that biosin
which was then led by ceo bill
steingarten and headquartered in
cupertino california had three
subsidiary companies nutrison pharmacin
and nano league technologies in that way
the novel foreshadows the rise of the
biosin we see in jurassic world dominion
an unethical corporation playing fast
and loose with food and medicine
the barbasol can with a secret
temperature temperature-controlled
compartment for dinosaur embryos is one
of jurassic park's most iconic props
viewers probably assumed it was lost for
good when nedry wrecked his jeep got
spat on to death by a dilophosaurus and
dropped it into a puddle of mud down a
hill miraculously that can shows up
again in jurassic world dominion where
returning character dr louis dodgson
appears to own it as part of some sort
of personal collection how did the can
get from the muck of isla nublar to the
mountains of northern italy for that
story you'll have to turn to your video
game console jurassic park the game
features a story line in which two
biosin employees go looking for nedry
and more importantly the can after he
doesn't make it to the drop point
depending on the choices the player
makes different circumstances befall the
barbasol camp however since biosin sent
people after it we can imagine that it
ended up in dodgson's hands eventually
which may have precipitated his rise to
ceo
dr henry wu is one of the jurassic park
franchise's cautionary tale characters
in the original he's a young and
overconfident scientist who fails to see
the flaws in his gene splicing plans
he's eager to push the limits of what
science can do as we see in jurassic
world where he's easily seduced by new
park owner simon masrani's interest in
creating dangerous hybrids scarier
cooler i believe is the word that you
use in your memo
though he gets redeemed in jurassic
world dominion he's still beholden to
the bad guys for most of the new trilogy
in jurassic world fallen kingdom he
escapes with a briefcase full of vials
containing embryos labeled with the
names of various species of dinosaurs
among them is one that hadn't appeared
in the franchise until now dreddnatis
drednatus is a recent discovery made by
paleontologists in 2014 the south
american titanosaur from the cretaceous
period may have been the largest land
animal of all time in fact its name
means fears nothing since at 85 feet
long and 65 tons there were likely few
predators that could have taken it down
dreadnatus appears in the valley of
biosin's sanctuary in jurassic world
dominion which is foreshadowed by this
quick shot of the contents of wu's
briefcase
the most readily apparent reference to
the original jurassic park comes about
three quarters of the way through
jurassic world dominion when all of our
protagonists are finally in one place
together owen and kayla have tracked
down claire ian with an assist from
ramsay has rescued alan ellie and maisie
and when their vehicle takes a tumble
owen and claire recognize macy's cries
just when they think the worst is behind
them a giganotosaurus approaches the
site of the crash what follows is a
fairly faithful recreation of the famous
t-rex scene from the original
must go faster
our heroes hide behind the flipped car
but as the gigantic predator turns the
corner they have to crawl through the
broken windows to the other side dr
malcolm gets stuck under the upside down
wreckage as the giganotosaurus spins it
around like a toy luckily it's
distracted with a torch allowing
everyone to flee to safety but the apex
predator's attack isn't over while in
the original jurassic park film the
t-rex wanders off after dr grant lex and
tim escaped down a cliffside in this
iteration the giganotosaurus follows the
crew up the observation tower ladder
until it's had enough of being prodded
zapped and shot
apparently even 65.5 million-year-old
theropods enjoy meta-humor biosin's
facilities in italy have the all-white
and ultra-modern look of a 21st century
tech company complete with zen-like
architecture and landscaping but things
are going to get pretty messy by the
time jurassic world dominion is over as
the film comes to its violent conclusion
and the forests are burning with
panicked flaming locusts the bios and
employees who've remained activate
implants in the living assets and corral
them into a containment area meanwhile
kayla is waiting to evacuate everyone in
one of bioson's sleek planes
giganotosaurus gets in between the
humans in the plane but he's just the
first predator on the scene kayla had
warned owen earlier that dodgson was
arrogant and short-sighted enough to put
two apex predators in the same territory
sure enough t-rex saunters into view and
stands in profile behind a circular
sculpture just long enough to compose a
live-action version of the jurassic park
logo
the jurassic park movies are just as
notorious for botching their real world
science as they are for topping the box
office most
paleontology-minded grade-schoolers can
rattle off a list of the things that are
wrong with the way dinosaurs are
depicted jurassic world dominion still
makes some mistakes but it uses its
script and its new creature designs to
correct some long-standing errors in the
original dr grant tells a bratty kid who
doesn't think velociraptors are scary
that their six-inch retractable claws
would have been used to disembowel him
he slashes at you
here or here
his dialogue in jurassic world dominion
sets the record straight as he clarifies
paleontologists now think he would have
just gone for the neck this is closer to
the truth these small raptors would have
just used their small claws to pin down
prey but you can only retcon the lore of
a six film franchise so much the final
jurassic park film also fixes some
visual and audio problems theropods like
raptors t-rex and giganotosaurus are
mostly shown with their palms facing
inward instead of dangling downward as
they should have been and their
vocalizations sound more like a low bird
or reptile bellowing than lion roars
which is also an improvement
the point is
you are alive
when they start to eat you
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you